so hello everybody
my name is michelle with 1l and this is
my talk
it takes a village to make a programmer
it's a talk in two parts so the first
part is my story and the second part
is a bunch of suggestions for you for
how you can help in your own village
so to start my story
i went to school for teaching and i
unfortunately graduated
at the height of the recession in the
united states so
i ended up not getting a teaching job i
was just substitute teaching which i
think is the most demoralizing job in
the world
so i was really unhappy for a while so
i realized i would have to move to get a
job and i thought if i'm going to move
away
for a job i'm going to move far far away
so after two years of substitute
teaching i moved to germany
when i got here i got a random office
job that wasn't going to really be
something permanent so i realized i had
a big decision to make
there were lots of different directions
my professional career could go
i had thrown around the idea of maybe
becoming a ux designer
i could teach english as a foreign
language i could try to go back to
teaching
i could keep this office job that i had
if i really wanted to
or i could do something totally
different
so one day at my office job i was an
office manager for a tour operator for
people who went on cruises
we got a bill from our programmers and
the bill was
really outrageous it was for this really
simple customer feedback form that we
had
asked them to create for us and i
remembered i had written back and forth
to them
about 10 times just with all these
little things that they could have done
to make it better
and i was taking german courses at the
time and afterwards i had gone out with
my classmates and i was so angry
and so upset about this i was raving to
them about how
i could do it better and you know what i
should be a programmer
i could do this and i didn't really take
myself very seriously
but one of my one of my classmates did
and so she emailed me about a course
that was going to be offered in berlin
called front-end web development
for beginners and it was really
expensive
so i sent an email to my brother saying
hey
there's this course want to sponsor me
lol
and i got the loving response from him
of nothing
so i wrote to him a second time saying
okay no
seriously what do you think will you
help me out
and he said yes so i took the course
and about halfway through the course
one of the people working for general
assembly the company where i took it was
also running
a group here in berlin called berlin
geek gets and i found out they were
offering a hackathon
so after six weeks with just knowledge
of html and css i participated in my
first hackathon
and this was where i had my holy [ __ ]
moment i was like oh my god
the energy that you could feel in the
room when everyone was just getting
together and
hashing out their ideas and forming
teams and working together the energy
was electric
i looked around and i just saw amazing
things happening
people were taking ideas that just
existed inside of their own head
and using nothing but their computer and
their hands and people around them they
were taking this idea
and making it into something that other
people could do and use and interact
with and i thought that was amazing
and i thought i want to do that and i
want to do that and i want to do that
and i want to be able to do everything
so i ended up quitting my office job
i finally realized what i wanted to do
and i thought okay
i'm going to do it berlin is the city
where you can take some time off and
and afford it so i decided to do this
so i had a lot of free time on my hands
once i was unemployed
and i heard about a conference called
uru camp it's a ruby conference that
happens here in berlin
and i'd never heard of anything like a
tech conference before
it was never something really on my
radar and i just thought hey
cool it's like an event where everyone's
interested in the same thing and they go
there and
hang out i want to go a couple of people
that i knew had gotten tickets through
rails girls
and they had gotten them for free
through a diversity outreach program but
there were no tickets left
so i couldn't afford to go myself being
unemployed
so they said hey why don't you follow
the twitter account maybe somebody will
sell theirs for free
or get get rid of it for a cheap price
so i started following the account and i
saw this guy bruno
and he tweeted so i have my euro camp
ticket and unfortunately i can't go
let's make it count give me a good
reason and it's free
give something back so i tweeted at him
right away and i wasn't sure if i would
get the ticket
i didn't know what other kind of people
i was competing with what reasons they
had but i said hey i'm really passionate
please
give me a chance and i did get the
ticket
and i got the ticket with several
stipulations he said okay you can have
the ticket but i have three rules
number one you have to have fun and you
have to have a lot of fun
i said okay i can do that he said number
two
find my friend justine she's giving a
talk and give her a hug
i said okay i can do that too and he
said number three
i don't care what you do what it is but
somehow you
need to give back to the community and i
said okay i can do that
and so that's part of what i'm here
doing today hoping that i can inspire
you to give back to your communities as
well
so i went to the conference and it was
way more impactful on my life than i
ever could have imagined
it was where i took my first rails girls
workshop
and i decided i did not want to start
programming by learning rails
one of the girls that i attended with
went on to become one of my best friends
um i was exposed to the idea of
lightning talks for the first time and
that was the first time i thought to
myself hey
maybe i could be a speaker too five
minutes i can do that
and probably the most important thing
was
this talk that was given at the rails
girls workshop by another woman who had
changed careers one year after her first
rails girls workshop
and i don't remember a single thing
about her talk because i just sat there
the whole time after she had been
introduced thinking to myself
i'm going to do that and i'm going to do
it faster
and i'm going to do it better and since
then
she's actually seen me give this talk
and we've spoken about it and she's cool
with it because you know
you want your talk to impact people and
how effective is your talk if you don't
even have to give it for it to have such
a
profound inspiration right
so i attended this wonderful conference
and i was back to my unemployed life
and i had five really good days
five great days where i was working from
the moment i woke up
until a reasonable hour in the evening
keeping track of
what i was doing how much time i spent
learning each thing
and it was really productive first week
and after that everything went downhill
because i don't know how much you've
tried to do
completely on your own like this but
it's not easy
so after that it became a big struggle
but luckily at the same time i met
another guy named franxx who also quit
his job
and we had these really symbiotic
interests
where he was interested in learning more
about teaching i was interested in
learning more about programming
and those were both our respective
careers so we teamed up
and he became a real huge mentor for me
he would hang out with me
pair a program he would whip up a gist
and explain a concept if i was having
trouble getting it if we weren't
together
he wrote homework assignments for me he
really pushed my learning forward and
helped me to have somebody to rely on
somebody that i could trust and ask
questions and and really helped me
improve and expand my knowledge
soon after this because relying on
franxx wouldn't have been just enough
i found out about a program that was
being piloted in berlin called
hackership
and it's based on something called the
hacker school in new york
if you're familiar with that and
basically it's a full-time learning
program for programmers
of all ranges of levels of experience
and basically what you do is you come
together and
full time you're just working on
learning
on whatever whatever you're interested
in
and not only do you have
mentors provided for you but you're
working alongside other people so it's
kind of like a real academic
setting and it helps you have somewhere
to go and and
you get to put on workshops yourself and
one of the best parts about it was that
at the end of every week we had to give
presentations to the whole group
and so i got to practice my public
speaking and
i got to share what i was working on
during these six weeks which was a web
application that i was building
in ruby without any frameworks or any
libraries
except for the crypto stuff which i
the thing i was most proud of was the
user authentication system that i wrote
so that was really cool so that was for
six weeks and that really pushed my
learning forward
so just to recap on the timeline of this
situation
i had january 22nd of 2013 last year
that was when i wrote my first hello
world at this front-end web development
course
and january 21st
of this year 2014 i got not one but
two junior developer job offers once i
finally got over the fear of looking for
a job
so some really exciting news i work for
sociomantic and
the team that i started on was doing the
css for ad banners
so i had been doing just css pretty much
exclusively for the last six months but
i just found out this week i got
accepted to
a new team where i will be doing native
javascript
so yeah
yeah so i got accepted i i got this job
offer and i accepted it but because of
some
legal issues i had to wait about a month
and a half before
i could start working so again i had
some more free time so i decided to
apply to speak at my first conferences
so i got accepted to speak at my first
conference it was another ruby
conference
in uruguay and uruguay is pretty far
away from berlin
and something happens when you're
unemployed for seven months
you run out of money so i got accepted
to speak at this conference i was
invited to go
but i had no way to get there at the
urging of the conference organizers i
set up an indiegogo
and again the community overwhelmed me
with their support
i received donations in 24 hours i made
all the money i needed to cover flight
and and somewhere to stay
and just out of the generosity of
people's hearts most people
didn't even know me at all they just
read the little description i had of
this talk it's this talk that i'm giving
right now
and i have to thank a couple of people
as one of the rewards so thank you to
bruno dennis
david seth sven along with a dozen other
people who helped me to get there
so yeah
so thank you to them so as i've said the
community has done
so much for me and so much to help me
get to where i am today and that now i
would like to give you some suggestions
for how you can help in your own
communities
so i'm going to go through a list of
suggestions with
some different resources based on what
resources you have
and i hope that there's something for
everybody here
so this is how to help in your own
village
if you have a little bit of time just a
little bit of time there's still things
you can do
the first thing is you can give
encouragement
it's such a simple thing but it can have
such a huge impact
i can't tell you how many days that i
was learning programming and
i would just get stuck on a concept it
just would not click in my head and i'd
think to myself
what are you doing are you crazy you
should just
go back to doing something else because
you're never going to figure this out
it's never going to work out and
and then inevitably living in an
international city like berlin i would
meet somebody and they'd say hey
what are you doing in berlin and i'd be
like oh well i'm changing careers i'm
learning how to program
and they'd be like no way that's so
awesome and i'd be like
oh yeah it kind of is awesome i'm
following my dreams
and they're like yeah and then it would
just kind of jolt me back into this oh
yeah
i have a real reason that i'm doing this
and and i do belong
programming so something as simple as
just a little hey
that's really cool can really make
somebody's day
something else you can do with just a
little bit of time is expose your
passions
i want you to take to twitter take to a
blog
a meet up start speaking about whatever
you're interested in everybody in this
room has something
that they're interested in that is
unique from
many other people but you don't know who
else shares this
unique interest of yours if you don't
talk about it and you don't share it
and especially consider ways that you
can be inviting to talk to people who
might not have as much knowledge about
this as you do
and think of ways that you can get other
people involved
if you have a little bit of time or a
lot of time
there are some options for you so
quality beginner friendly resources
there are two parts two parts to this so
the first is
just sharing them if you only have a
little bit of time you can find
quality resources and share them by
tweeting them or just telling people
about them
or if you have even more time maybe you
can write some yourself
because as you know there's such a
wealth of resources out there and they
are not
all created equal you can google
how to do something and find 25
different blog articles
and you know that some of these are crap
and some of these are going to be good
but
but you won't know if you're
inexperienced so
if you have any sort of motivation to
write some of these things please do it
okay maybe you don't have time but you
have money
you can be a sponsor
it is so easy to have so many excuses
why you don't want to try something new
or
get into a new field or get started
you can really talk people out of a lot
of excuses but you can't talk someone
out of not having enough money
so you could sponsor someone for a
course or a workshop like my brother did
for me
or some other creative way to use the
resource that you have
you can also send somebody to a
conference as we said before
a conference is so much more than just
talks and just
professional development you there's
networking you meet friends
there can be workshops you just get so
much more from a conference than
than you can really imagine it can be a
really great place
but as you know they can be really
expensive so if you
have some way to get an extra ticket or
if you're an organizer jsconf did a
really great job with these diversity
tickets where you could buy one and send
someone else with it
something like that is really awesome
and if you have a lot of time
you should become a mentor this is the
single most
important thing that you can do for
anyone who's starting out or changing
careers
it is just the biggest thing that you
can do to help someone
if you have somebody to trust and
somebody you can ask these questions to
and you can share your experiences with
and there's also so many different ways
that you can do this
it doesn't have to mean just one thing
so you could meet for lunch as often as
monthly or weekly whatever you can
commit to you could pair program with
people
you could simply offer advice by email
in my
in the last year or so i found out about
this program called
mentoring.is and it's a distributed
mentoring movement
and basically what it is is you add
slash mentoring to your personal website
and they give you a text and everything
that you can use to just
say to people hey i'm open to being a
mentor this is how to get in touch with
me
and it's a really great way if you don't
know how to get started or how to get
involved in your community you can
simply add this and start sharing it
and if you have space and time there's
more options
we need you to create safe spaces
what do i mean by that safe spaces can
be anything like a hackathon
a workshop a study group it could mean a
women-only group or some sort of
minority only group
and i want to make a point about this
there seems to be some controversy where
people think that these
whatever only spaces are exclusive but
they're not
they're actually inclusive what they do
is they include people who otherwise
would have been excluded whether they
would have felt uncomfortable or unsafe
or
just couldn't get in due to overcrowding
whatever reason it is it includes more
people who otherwise wouldn't have been
included and why are safe spaces
important
they're really important because this is
where you challenge yourself
and take risks and stretch your limits
you can't find out what new things you
can do if you don't feel comfortable
enough to try
new things so that's why safe spaces are
so important for us to have these
community spaces
and finally if you have courage i urge
you to tell your story
especially if you have a story that
doesn't fit the the mold of the
stereotypical kid who started
programming when he
could write and has been doing it his
entire life
i have a quote for you from a
documentary called misrepresentation
it says you cannot be what you cannot
see
so of course there are exceptions but if
you
can be a role model or a hero for
somebody where they can identify with
something with you
and if you're a little bit different
than than other people
that can be a really amazing amazing
way to help out by just becoming a
figure for people
so what now
i'd like to take one moment to give a
shout out to hard work and to
acknowledge the hard work that i did put
in and that other people like me have
put in because even with all the help in
the world it wouldn't have been possible
and i just think it's important to to
acknowledge
and i also have one more quote for you
it's by tal ben shahar who's a
positive psychologist from harvard and
he says
there's so much benefit to the person
who contributes to others that i often
think there is no more selfish act than
a generous act
so that means that anything you do for
other people
you're really doing for yourself and any
of these ways that you can help out you
will feel a reward
and it will feel good and i'm i can
promise you that
so now i would like you to please return
to your villages
and make some programmers
thank you
thank you i have some resources for you
i will tweet it out later it's just got
some different things like what i use to
learn some programming the mentoring
link
different diversity groups if you're
interested in learning more about how to
diversify in your own company
and some different coding group for kids
and so again i would like to say thank
you to everybody who's helped me
thank you for listening and thank you
from the future for all of the people
that you will help
thank you for the people you've been
helping and thank you for everyone
you've helped already
thanks